le 18 décembre, la Chambre des
représentants a confirmé son
devoir constitutionnel et a voté des articles
d'impeachment contre le président
des États-Unis
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
quitter ses fonctions avant la fin de mon mandat
est odieux à tous les instincts
de mon  corps mais en tant que président je dois faire passer
les intérêts de l'Amérique en premier donc
je démissionnerai de la présidence à compter de
demain midi je veux que vous m'écoutiez je vais le répéter
je n'ai pas eu de
relations sexuelles avec cette femme
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
le Sénat convoquera est une cour d'
impeachment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
leurs actions dépravées aujourd'hui brazii Les
démocrates de Nancy Pelosi
se sont marqués d'un marché éternel
[Musique]
Je jure
chaque jour au procès du
destitution de Donald John Trump le
président des États-Unis
maintenant Pandey vous ferez une
justice impersonnelle conformément à la Constitution
et aux lois alors aidez-vous Dieu je fais
[Musique]